Pokemon go is based on one simple
concept catching pokemon in the real
world and now we know how it's going to
work I'm Tony and this game spot news
update will help you catch them all
after some gameplay leaked from South by
Southwest Pokemon trainers all around
the world had questions about how the
game would work so here's what we know
your phone will vibrate when a Pokemon
is nearby and you'll find them in their
usual habitats squirtle near the water
aatish in the grass you know the deal
then you can use touch controls to catch
the wild Pokemon you come across the
more you catch the higher your trainer
level and the more powerful Pokemon
you'll encounter you'll also be able to
find Pokemon eggs that hatch after you
take enough steps and some Pokemon will
evolve if you catch enough of the same
species all of this can be linked to the
Pokemon go plus bracelet which will
alert you of any nearby Pokemon no price
has been announced for the device yet
Pokemon goes first field test is
happening this month in Japan so we
should hear more about gameplay very
soon other territories may get field
tests as well but the pokemon company
hasn't announced anything yet in the
meantime you can stick with GameSpot for
all the latest about everyone's favorite
pocket monsters
you
you